wenn alle sagen Sie möchten dass sich
die Führung der Hamburger SPD übernehme
dann bekommen alle das was sie bestellt
hat ich weiß nicht ob man das hier sagen
kann was ist die Bazooka mit der wir
gibt das Notwendige tun der 24 Februar
2022 markiert eine Zeitenwende Olaf
Scholz inszeniert sich als einer der
führt aber ist das so pflegt er nicht
eher den Führungsstil von Angela Merkel
abwarten bis ich Mehrheiten abzeichnen
sogar Scholz selbst hat sich mit seiner
Vorgängerin verglichen 2018 erlebt als
er in Hamburg backing als Bürgermeister
und sagt dann naja ich gehe jetzt nach
Berlin
und am Ende der Legislaturperiode wird
die Merkel nicht mehr antreten und dann
bin ich ja da ich bin ja so eine Art
männliche merke als Kanzler der
Ampelkoalition tritt er jetzt häufiger
als Vermittler auf macht Zugeständnisse
und zögert was aber sagt uns das über
den Mann ist es nur seine Art eine
ideologisch weit gespreizte Koalition zu
führen oder ist der Kanzler von den
großen Herausforderungen der Zeit
Pandemie Krieg Inflation verunsichert
kann der kanzlerkrise und wer steuert
die Ampel wohin das schauen wir uns
jetzt genauer an herzlich Willkommen zu
Kontext an Selbstvertrauen mangelt es
Olaf Scholz wahrlich nicht 2011 holte er
in Hamburg die absolute Mehrheit für die
SPD und wird erster Bürgermeister der
Hansestadt Zugeständnisse an andere
Regierungspartner völlig unnötig
minutenlanger Applaus für einen
Wahlsieger das bei der SPD
Seltenheitswert oder Scholz holt den
Hamburg die absolute Mehrheit 2015 dann
aber braucht die SPD zur
Regierungsmehrheit ein Koalitionspartner
die Grünen schlagen ein und lernen Olaf
Scholz kennen als harten Verhandler und
dominanten Gesprächspartner ein Kürzel
macht die Runde
OWD Olaf will das er machtvolle Olaf
Scholz hatte vor allem Disziplin
erwartet ansonsten die Grünen weitgehend
ignoriert als die SPD 2018 auf
Bundesebene erneut in die Große
Koalition geht übernimmt Olaf Scholz des
Amtes Bundesfinanzministers und wir
schon damals vertrauten erzählte mit dem
klaren Ziel nach Merkel der nächste
Bundeskanzler zu werden eine Idee auf
die außer ihm damals nicht allzu viele
gekommen werden
zwar war er laut ZDF Politbarometer in
dieser Zeit der beliebteste
Sozialdemokrat das spricht dafür dass
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger empfinden
dass das Amt in guten Händen ist aber in
der eigenen Partei ist seine Position
umstritten denn damals wie heute ist
sein Name eng verbunden mit unliebsamen
Projekten wie der Agenda 2010 im
Wettkampf um den Parteivorsitz bekommt
er das schmerzlich zu spüren Olaf wie
kann man mit Glaubwürdigkeit jemanden
erklären dass derjenige der uns letzten
Endes auch maßgeblich beteiligt in
Funktion in dieses Tal der Tränen diese
Niederungen der heutigen Ergebnisse
geführt hat heute zukünftig für
Glaubwürdigkeit und soziale
Gerechtigkeit in der SPD stehen da habe
ich eine erklärungsprobleme ich bin der
Meinung dass ich ein echter
truly Sozialdemokrat bin die Folge der
Vorwürfe Scholz scheitert die
Rückendeckung aus den eigenen Reihen war
zu schwach sie sind sich nicht sicher ob
der instandhafter Sozialdemokrat ist in
so langen Jahren der
Regierungsverantwortung hat man sich
schon in in Kompromisse gegeben in
vielen langen Jahren die tatsächlich die
Sozialdemokratie auch nicht standhaft
die Niederlage im Kampf um den
Parteivorsitz ist vielleicht die
schmerzhafteste die Olaf Scholz erleidet
es ist ganz klar dass wir nach dieser
großen Koalition spätestens in ganz
andere Richtungen aufbrechen wollen und
dafür also kann Olaf Scholz nicht stehen
ich glaube das war es ja auch ich halte
es auch weiterhin für richtig dass er
nicht Parteivorsitzender geworden ist
dieser Ausschnitt findet sich auch in
der Dokumentation
Machtwechsel der Kampf ums Kanzleramt
den Beitrag haben wir Ihnen in der
Mediathek bereitgestellt in der
Niederlage zeigt sich dann dennoch das
hartnäckige Selbstvertrauen des Olaf
Scholz er bleibt überzeugt dass er der
nächste Kanzler wird er sollte Recht
behalten doch dazu später mehr dieselben
Personen die vorher verhindert hatten
das Scholz Parteivorsitzender wird die
unterstützten ihn jetzt einmütig bei
seiner Kanzlerkandidatur um kurz vor elf
am Vormittag eröffnet Saskia esken
praktisch den Bundestagswahlkampf mit
einem launigen Tweet olaf hat den
Kanzler Wumms vom Vorstand und Präsidium
einstimmig zum Kandidaten nominiert
was er kann ist jemand der nicht die
großen Worte schwingt sondern der uns
sicher durch die Krise gebracht hat
bisher wir werden uns daran gewöhnen
müssen die politischen Zeiten werden
bunter einer muss ja die bunte wilde
Welt auch ein bisschen Ordnung
reinbringen dass der Kollege da hinten
und da kommt er dann wieder der Anspruch
des nunmehr Kanzlerkandidaten Scholz und
was uns auch unterscheidet von denen mit
denen wir im Wettbewerb stehen ist dass
wir führen können mit dem Eintritt in
die Koalitionsverhandlungen aber wird
scheinbar alles anders Scholz wechselt
in die Rolle eines Vermittlers zwar
setzt die SPD sozialpolitische Anliegen
wie die Erhöhung des Mindestlohns oder
die Kindergrundsicherung durch doch vor
allem der Juniorpartner FDP gilt als
großer Gewinner der Verhandlungen weder
werden höhere Einkommen noch Unternehmen
stärker besteuert es gibt keinen
mietenstopp und kein Tempolimit die
möchtegern Koalitionäre haben sich
vorerst auf eine gemeinsame Sprache
geeinigt sie soll überdecken wie groß
die Hürden wie lang der Weg zueinander
sein wird nie zuvor haben liberale grüne
und Sozialdemokraten gemeinsam eine
Bundesregierung gebildet für die FDP
wäre eine Koalition mit der Union vielen
natürlicher gewesen aber letztere erwies
sich in den koalitions Sondierungen als
regierungsunfähig blieb also nur die
Ampel und die versuchte das Beste draus
zu machen wollte so der
Koalitionsvertrag mehr Fortschritt wagen
es geht uns nicht um eine Politik des
kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenners sondern um
eine Politik der großen Wirkung eine
Politik der großen Wirkung soll es also
sein das sollten wir doch einmal an
konkreten Beispielen überprüfen die
Entscheidung über die Impfpflicht die
Lieferung schwerer Waffen an die Ukraine
und der Umgang mit den sozialen Folgen
der Inflation zuerst also die
Impfpflicht Scholz kündigt die
Impfpflicht für März an dann aber wird
immer klarer dass in der FDP eine Reihe
von hartnäckigen impfpflichtgegnern
nicht mitmachen wird ich setze mich
aktiv dafür ein dass es dazu kommt bei
dieser Frage ist mir die innere
Verfasstheit des Bundeskanzlers relativ
egal genauso wie ihm ja meine innere
Verfasstheit egal ist und sonst hätte er
sich hingestellt und erklärt er sei für
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht also ich
persönlich habe immer gesagt dass ich
mich für eine allgemeine Impfpflicht aus
bei dieser ersten großen Entscheidung
findet die Koalition keine Einigung die
Entscheidung wird zur Gewissensfrage
erklärt also Abstimmung ohne
Fraktionszwang in der Konsequenz bleibt
ein gemeinsamer Gesetzentwurf aus aber
nicht so wie sie es machen um
offensichtlich hier davon abzulenken
dass ihnen ihre eigenen Regierung keine
Mehrheit haben für das was aus dieser
Fraktion kommt trotz aller Bemühungen
der erste Versuch des Kanzlers Führung
zu zeigen misslingt für ihn eine
Niederlage es gibt im Bundestag keine
gesetzgebungs Mehrheit für eine
Impfpflicht und das ist die Realität die
wir jetzt als Ausgangspunkt für unser
Handeln nehmen müssen so sehe ich das
bedauere kommen wir zum zweiten Punkt
die Diskussion um die Lieferung schwerer
Waffen an die Ukraine der 24 Februar
2022 markiert eine Zeitenwende wie Sie
wissen haben wir gestern entschieden
dass Deutschland der Ukraine Waffen zur
Verteidigung des Landes liefern wird
schon kurz nach dem Angriff Russlands
verspricht Scholz der Ukraine Beistand
und Waffen über Art und Ausmaß der
Lieferung aber herrscht in der Koalition
Uneinigkeit Grüne und FDP unterstützen
die Forderung der Ukraine nach direkter
Lieferung von Panzern und anderen
schweren Waffen die Ukraine braucht
weiteres militärisches Material vor
allen Dingen auch schwere Waffen und
jetzt ist keine Zeit für Ausreden
sondern jetzt ist Zeit für Kreativität
und Pragmatismus wir müssen alles was in
unserer Macht steht tun um der Ukraine
zum Sieg zu verhelfen der Druck auf den
zögernden Kanzler wächst nicht zuletzt
durch massive internationale Kritik
aber auch zu Hause wächst die Kritik
Scholz Zufriedenheitswerte sinken
natürlich auch die Unsicherheit weil er
vielleicht ahnt dass die nicht so
unrecht haben gerade wenn sie aus dem
Eindruck von der Ukraine kommen nachdem
auch die USA schwere Waffen an die
Ukraine liefern lässt sich der Kanzler
ein auf einen Kompromiss der Gepard
Panzer ihn liefert Deutschland nun an
die Ukraine damit also schwere Waffen
eine Kehrtwende Olaf Scholz nennt das
Besondere Waffenlieferungen Deutschland
hat unter meiner Führung entschieden
dass wir überhaupt Waffen in die Ukraine
liefern das war ein Bruch mit Regeln die
wir viele Jahrzehnte anders hatten bis
Ende Juli lieferte Deutschland der
Ukraine zweimal schwere
Artilleriegeschütze unter anderem aus
Beständen der Bundeswehr aber auch jetzt
bleibt der Vorwurf zu wenig und zu spät
und das führt uns zum dritten und
letzten Punkt sein Umgang mit den
sozialen Folgen der Inflation die nicht
zuletzt in der corona-pandemie und dem
Krieg in der Ukraine Wurzel wir werden
alles dafür tun dass die Bürger und
Bürger durch diese schwierige Zeit
kommen die SPD will Vermögen umverteilen
die
fdp-steuererhöhungen kategorisch
ausschließen und die Grünen sich vor
allem für klimagerechten Wohlstand
einsetzen und der Kanzler er versucht zu
vermitteln in seiner ideologisch weit
gespreizten Koalition
wir machen Bus und Bahnfahren so billig
wie es in Deutschland wahrscheinlich
noch nie war einen neuen euro-ticket
sich sehen nicht die Gelder dafür wir
haben zugelassen dass zu viel über
Waffenlieferungen und zu wenig über
gestiegene Lebenshaltungskosten und zu
wenig über gestiegene Energiepreise auch
in der Kommunikation geredet wurde als
Teil der entlastungspakete setzen dann
die Grünen des 9-euro-ticket durch und
die FDP den Tankrabatt beim Thema der
unverdienten übergewinne aber bleibt der
Kanzler beharrlich und nachdem sich
sogar die Mehrheit der fdp-wählerinnen
und Wähler für eine Zusatzsteuer auf
außergewöhnliche Gewinne ausspricht
geraten die Liberalen zunehmend unter
Druck am 3 September einigt sich die
Ampel wenn auch unter anderem Namen das
erste ist dass wir die zufallsgewinne
die jetzt auf dem Strommarkt erzielt
werden abschöpfen denn da gibt es ja
ganz viele früher mal die
übergewinnsteuer die eigentlich SPD und
Grüne wollten oder ist das
übergewinne ist jedenfalls Gewinne die
nichts mit dem zu tun hat was man
eigentlich wirtschaftlich tut es ist
keine Steuer und es ist auch nicht für
allgemeine Zwecke einsetzbar sondern es
wird eine erlösbremse geschaffen auch
wenn aus der übergewinnsteuer eine
Abschöpfung von zufallsgewinn wurde in
der Konsequenz werden Krisen Profiteure
und profiteureinnen jetzt zur Kasse
gebeten und deren Vermögen umverteilt
damit setzt Olaf Scholz nach seinem
Scheitern bei der Impfpflicht und seinem
Einlenken bei der Waffenlieferung ein
wichtiges Ziel der SPD in der Ampel
durch wenn auch durch Druck der Mehrheit
erzeugt und weniger durch Führungsstärke
und Sie haben ja gesehen dass wir jetzt
sehr geschlossen als Regierung sehr
weitreichende Entscheidung getroffen
haben seit Amtsantritt der Ampel Akteure
haben sich die Ereignis überschlagen
getrieben von Krieg Pandemie und
Inflation musste der Kanzler des Land
außenpolitisch
positionieren und dabei versuchen eine
ideologisch gefächerte Koalition
zusammenzuhalten
Olaf Scholz wollte unbedingt Kanzler
werden Führung wurde versprochen aber
häufiger angekündigt als erkennbar
umgesetzt in Zeiten der Krisen bleiben
ihm oft nur Kompromisse regieren als
Reaktion das kommt einem aus 16 Jahren
Merkel durchaus vertraut vor was denken
sie geht der Kanzler zu viele
Kompromisse ein oder ist das in so
schwierigen Zeiten genau der richtige
Ansatz schreiben Sie es uns in die
Kommentare und abonnieren Sie doch gerne
auch unseren Kanal um keine Folge
Kontext mehr zu verpassen